lizzy shanks is on fire
the russians are headed this way and
there seems to be little they can do to
stop them
the city is coming under relentless
shelling its streets are largely empty
of people
those still here cower and emerge just
to get supplies under constant
explosions
[Music]
do you not get scared of those
explosions
it's very scary julia tells us if
something happens we just have to rush
inside she says
there are families still here all
exhausted by this never-ending
bombardment
it's a stalemate
two weeks before the war started an old
relative told me it's going to happen
[Music]
can you imagine in the 21st century and
we have a war and we speak the same
language
the cities twinned with several donetsk
with just the sovereignettes river
dividing them
they're watching and listening to the
unremitting march on their neighbors and
know that they're next
but most won't even have seen these
pictures released on social media
apparently showing chechen fighters in
the centre of severe donetsk
sky news has verified the location but
the date is unknown
the fighters are filmed being greeted by
the residents as they boast of
liberating the city
and tell them they have complete control
of the residential sector
when we spent two days inside several
donets last weekend
we saw the barrage of attacks as the
russian troops pushed in
and how much the residents relied on
humanitarian aid being delivered
to tell you the truth elena says i can't
believe i'm living in a shelter at my
age she's 65. i'm like a homeless person
she says
and now all that aid they've depended on
has been cut off by the fighting
in this atmosphere everyone's a suspect
and the lizzie shanks police are leaping
on any strange behavior as they hunt for
collaborators
the russian forces are accused of
deliberately shelling an evacuation bus
killing a french journalist who was
inside the police are building a dossier
of potential war crimes these people is
another
they know
this yes yes of course
this is not war on frontline this is a
war with civilian and without city and
town and destroyed
all life
the ukrainians seem unable to stop the
russians who are advancing on three
fronts in the donbass
they're pushing on flanks in the south
east and from the north towards here the
city of slaviansk
there's been a dramatic uptick in
attacks over the past 48 hours
taking slavians would be a huge symbolic
victory for the russians it was first
captured by pro-kremlin fighters briefly
in 2014 but then taken back by the
ukrainians they don't want to lose it
again
but this is an indication of just how
savage the battle is in the donbass
a number of these homes
were just burnt out entirely i mean this
one's
just one charge remains very little
left of it every room
destroyed and just
ashes and embers
[Music]
so many in the domes are weary of war
they don't want to divide they just want
the brutality to stop
i just want peace she says i just want
them to leave us alone
but it doesn't look like that is
happening anytime soon alex crawford sky
news in the donbass